The Joe Rogan experience.
What makes you nervous about
this? Alright, three big areas.
First humans and all of buys,
incredibly complex.
Homeo talk about genetic code,
which is mindbogglingly complex,
but our genetics exists
within the incredible,
incredibly complex systems biology.
We have all of these things like our
microbiome, our virome are proteome,
the Metabolome, and then that exists
within the context of our environment.
And everything's always changing and,
and interacting.
And so we are messing and we have the
tools to mess and we will mess because
we're this hubristic species with
these really complex ecosystems,
including ourselves. We don't fully
understand. That's number one,
two and you mentioned it
before, this issue of, of
equity. What happens if we have,
every technology has to have first
adopters. If you don't have it,
you never get the technology.
But what happens if a group of people
move much more quickly than other people,
whether it's real or not, even if they
believe it's real. You could imagine big,
dangerous societal changes.
And the third big area is diversity.
And we think about diversity.
We think why it's great to have
diverse workplaces and schools. And,
and we're more better people for
it and we're more competitive.
The diversity is something much,
much, much deeper. In Darwinian terms,
diversity is random mutation.
Like that's our core survival strategy
as a species. If we didn't have that,
you could say we distilled be single
cell organisms but we wouldn't,
we would have died because the environment
would have changed and we wouldn't
have had the built in resilience to adapt.
Yeah.
That is really important when
thinking about diversity, right? Yeah.
We need a non uniformity when it
comes to our own biology. Yeah.
Because you a bunch of different kinds
of people. We have to have it be as,
even if we optimize for this
world, um, the world will change.
There's no good and bad in evolution.
There's just well suited for
a particular environment.
If that environment changes,
the best suited person for your old
environment may be the least suited person
for the new environment.
So even if we have things that seem real,
like really great ideas now,
like optimizing health.
So if you have sickle cell disease,
you're probably going to die
and you're going to die young.
And it's going to be excruciating pain,
excruciatingly painful.
And so you would say, well, let's
just get rid of sickle cell disease,
which we can do.
But if you are a recessive carrier of
the single of the sickle cell disease
gene,
you don't have it.
You're just carrying it and you have a
pretty significant risk of passing it on
to your kids, but you also have an
additional resistance to malaria.
And so we are probably are almost
certainly carrying around all kinds of
recessive traits, maybe even ones that we
don't like that are harming us now. Um,
but that could be some protection against
some future danger that we don't yet
understand or how are haven't faced.
And so the challenge is that diversity
has just happened to us for 4 billion
years now we're going to have
to choose it. And that's a big,
it's a big challenge for us.
So essentially we were
going to have without doubt,
some unintended consequences,
some unintended domino effect,
things that are going to take
place that we really can't predict.
We just have to kind of go along with
this technology and see where it leads us
as it improves.
Like if you go back and look at surgeries
from the 1950s comparison to surgery
of 2019 giant leaps,
I mean,
I would never advise someone to get
their knee operated by a 1950s physician.
Right? Right. Yeah. Right.
But that's kind of someone's going to
have to be an early adopter when it comes
to these genetic therapies.
Yeah, no, I agree with you.
But where I would slightly,
or I would add to what you're
saying is these technologies,
they're going to happen,
they're going to play out,
and what's at play now is not where
these technologies are going to advance.
They will,
it will do it.
They will advance in a way that is
going to just blow people's minds.
What's at play is what are the values
that we are going to weave into the
decision making process so that we can
get a better outcome than we otherwise
would have had and that that's
what, in my view, that's the real,
the important issue.
Now.